[Music]  once upon a time you all lived together  then the wars came  and you ran off into your little corners  of the world  [Music]  now you're scared for your life  all you have to do  is pledge your loyalty all kneel before  king canoe  [Music]  want be the greatest fighter to ever  exist  i will teach you to use your senses to  live not to die to be the best warrior  take your stance  let's protect earthrealm  in this right now this is my fight  [Music]  your souls  are mine i thought that slime did  nothing  you are the challenge good  time to die  those with power  no one stands a chance  [Music]  is it just me or is it getting a little  bit nippy out here  he's here  and there is nothing you can do  to stop  [Music]  [Music]  you